[Applause]
naturally affections
in horror story and the creator of the
campaign glam up the midterms Billy
Eichner Billy you are very funny and I
think it's great that you're turning
your talents now to something a little
more serious you want people to vote and
we can't get enough people out there
getting people to vote so glam up the
midterms it's like 20 years ago they
call that rock the boat right it's still
around actually really amazing work yeah
but I started this campaign with my
friends at Funny or Die which is the
production company started by Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay who've been
producing Billy on the street for many
years
by the way I was just making out with
George Will backstage
[Laughter]
so it took me 25 years to get him here
well to go [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
another 25 years we'll come back talk
about voting yeah so I started this
campaign with Funny or Die called glam
up the midterms which is our fun way of
trying to make the midterms which sounds
like it sure sounds like homework to a
lot of young people sound fun and
exciting and sexy Millennials
Millennials yeah are you a millennial I
am NOT have a lot of young fans you know
Billy on the street has a quenching um
following and a lot and a big following
online right and so I thought you know
I'm always tweeting angry things every
day as many of us are and there's a
reason to do that right that is
productive but I wanted to do something
that felt productive and that write a
tangible result and so we're doing this
campaign to get young people to vote I
saw a statistic which said in the last
midterm in 2014 only depending on which
report you read only 12 to 20 percent of
Millennials who could vote did vote Wow
and that's a staggeringly low number and
so we're generation to figure aren't
they I mean that they're very bright
they're even like aware that there's
very self-entitled but they just can't
stop it I did ask my Twitter following
after the California primary where the
numbers are up the numbers in California
were up on June 5th that's a good start
especially in CA 14 I know we have this
crazy jungle primary but when I asked my
following why the ones who didn't vote
in California didn't vote if they could
I got a lot of frustrating but honest
responses and it means that people are
still really [ __ ] lazy right like
you're putting on shows like you've done
this before and like you have to be
registered to get in the show it's
basically a bribe exactly is it is it
wrong to bribe people to vote why don't
we just pay them
well we can pay them and so we're gonna
put on a show you make the costume I'll
get the barn
no but the shows that we're doing are
actually they're very locally curated
Will Ferrell and I did a show in
district 49 in Oceanside here where
we'll played Ron Burgundy who has a very
direct connection to San Diego not we
weren't only entertaining the people
that came who registered to vote but we
also brought up young local leaders
community leaders kids working on daca
and LGBT equality and March for our
lives in that district to come on stage
with will and I and talk about the work
they're doing and it was it was very
inspiring so today